we see the clients you know we have more
than 300 advertisers
and we're we're doing three times on
revenues since night
2019 each year we're doing three times
each year on the revenues
and it's it makes me feel like you know
it's you can't you can put a price on
that feeling so i guess that's what
makes sense to me
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders we're in
influential marketing today
meet liav rafael
the co-founder and ceo of humans ai an
ai powered platform that makes
influencer marketing accessible reliable
and trustworthy for marketers and
influencers he has extensive experience
in devops big data and machine learning
all of which was acquired through his
five-year military experience with this
themed intelligence unit 8200 of the
israeli army
it's a pleasure speaking to you in tel
aviv university right before you're
about to give a talk about your journey
from ai at 8200 working on some of the
most interesting platforms that i got to
experience myself also in the unit
but transitioning then to influencer
marketing not just influencer marketing
but building a sas platform to enable
influencer marketing so you know you're
leveraging technology to look at a shift
in consumer behavior for the way that we
interact with we know products and how
we gain trust for using using the
products it's no longer just the the
same television actors that are that are
supporting the product it's you know
influencers all around us so liam thank
you so much for being here tell me a
little bit about yourself how do you get
how do you get to what you do today
so i'm originally from a lot that's
where i grew up
i studied computers as a kid
after school classes and during the high
school
i learned how to code and basically got
my experience during
um
when i was a teenager
um i loved computer and then i got to
the the unit 8200 which is the
intelligence unit as you know
um i served there
as a
software developer and then i went for
the to officer school came back i was um
commanding chief of one of the courses
um for the training in the in the bahad
bad hamashes
and
obviously after that i was a software
team leader
where i met my co-founders today so we
are five co-founders that started humans
right after the army we're all served
together
and we dealt with a lot of data machine
learning and analyzing behaviors
um we took the same expertise that we
have
and one day
it's at lunch time and
right really
base we spoke to one of our friends who
was a party organizer uh and he told us
that he's doing that thing to make some
money on the side it was a side gig
and we asked them but how can you bring
consumers how can you bring traffic to
your parties and then he told us that he
pays a lot of money to beautiful girls
on instagram and has a lot of followers
and they bring the audiences and we i
remember i've asked him in the in the
lunch time but it's is it working do you
how how do you know how much to pay who
do you pay for how can you track that
and that friend you know in the army in
in the base we have a lot of smart
people and he has a master's degrees in
mathematics
so he was a very smart guy my friend and
and we all asked him but how do you know
how to pay them and how much and he
didn't really had any answers so i
remember that was my aha moment you know
where i started to asking the same
questions i asked google and i found out
there is a landscape called influencer
marketing i found out that he has
problems but also
many other brands across the world has
problems and we as five
software developers from the army from
schwannoma time
we knew how to deal with big data so we
created algorithms
for social media behavior analysis and
then we had the ability to understand
users to segment them into demographics
interests whether they're real or fake
users and with that technology we
basically changed the influencers
landscape we allowed brands to find the
most relevant collaborations for them
and
like now we're four years after we have
more than 300 advertisers like
unilever zara kimberly clark
cortex
terminolics many other brands in seven
countries we're around
65 employees in the company
and we have the headquarters here in tel
aviv so
yeah so it's it's growing pretty fast
and
getting much more traction recently so
i i guess they i guess the old landscape
beautiful view
leave take me you know higher level
what's happening with influencer
marketing and specifically where does
technology fit into
this new notion of finding
influencers micro or macro influencers
and allowing them
to work with brands to advertise
properly what what is happening here
from a technological perspective that is
the innovation here
so
the thing
everyone must remember is that
the number one rule for influencer
marketing is trust
you have to trust
the
the influencer that you're following
that's what the first change that it's
not a banner that it pops out to your
website or during your
instagram scrolling but it's
you're willing to get the content
trust the person now organically getting
the content organically exactly now
organically
yeah you the advertisement is on an
instagram page a twitter page a youtube
page a twitch page and it's not your
page as an advertiser or as a brand it's
the creators page
the first thing that is you know
innovation in what we do is the
measurement abilities we can measure
real exposure we can measure real
traction we can provide you with a lot
of data using our techniques and our
pixel that we implement
within the actual pages and we're
allowed to say
okay this creator brought
100 visitors to your website that
generated 50 000 in revenues to your
business
and the simple
sentence that i've just said is
something that no one else can say
um only humans
and the reason is that we connect and we
created the ecosystem so one way
is to have the creators on board to your
platform then we analyze their social
behavior and social influence using a
bunch of machine learning algorithms for
example image analysis further content
posts
nlp analysis for the text they use and
then we understand more information
about each user and finally we
understand if it's a real or a fake user
you are more than 20
fake users only on instagram you can buy
likes you can buy things forward
yes so you want to be smart when you
approach them i don't know if you saw
the movie the hbo documentary about fake
and famous but they basically took a a
social media account instagram account
they bought followers and comments for
that account and they sold it as an
influencer to one of the leading brands
in the world
and they showed the problem
yeah it's a documentary it's like it's
very fascinating and what we do is we
basically solve this issue using
measurements and analytics technology
that we developed
so i think that the entire market is
going for a more um measurable approach
the creators now
have their own brands they're becoming
the new advertisers the social platforms
themselves giving providing tools for
their creators to sell content to sell
products and merchandise
and humans is right there to make sure
to facilitate the entire process between
the different platforms between the
different creators
that's why we're here
incredible incredible if you're looking
today the marketplace so you're serving
both the influencers you're also serving
the the marketers the advertisers and
you're at the end you're serving also
the people that are organically getting
this exposure
where is the ch where is the most
challenging piece is it the the what
you're just mentioning the fake versus
famous is it more about you know the the
way that you're you're leveraging a
consumer friendly uh process for the
uh influencers or where does the
challenge
lie the biggest challenge when it comes
to the influencer ecosystem and creator
you're right you have a triangle on the
one side you have the creator on the
other side you have the brand and on the
above side you have the consumer and
the from my perspective the most
important piece of that is obviously the
consumer because what connects everyone
together
is the trust the trust factor
and if you don't have trust within the
consumer you're going to lose the trust
within the creator which obviously going
to lose you the trust with the brands
so
once you start and figuring out which
are the best you know you
you start the process by having a
product and then you want to find
who can send these product messages out
in the most performing way so you have
to find the audiences the consumers that
are interested in this product and then
who can influence them
so the most important part and the most
challenging part
is to understand the audiences online on
instagram on tiktok on twitter etc
and then to find the influential
and to my recommendation micro and nano
accounts that are the best fit to
influence this
target audience
beautiful so you're not just the
platform for allowing the advertisers to
enter influencer marketing and for the
influencers to participate you're also
doing targeted analysis
for how to most effectively make it
happen right it's not just let's take
this tv persona and hire them because
they're generally famous it's no let's
take this specific one they may have
only 15 000 followers but boy these are
the exact followers that you as an as an
advertiser want right
exactly we
core technology of humans is to identify
the audiences and that's what we we were
granted by the israeli chief scientist
office for one million dollars only for
the machine learning that we developed
to identify audiences based on their
social behavior
and on top of that we developed the sas
platform that allows you
to insert a brief and to find
influencers and then approach them
manage them and finally pay them but the
entire ecosystem the entire workflow is
on the platform and we do believe that
the biggest challenge you know is to
identify the target audience
right right paint me a picture you know
two three years down the line where are
we heading with with influencer
marketing in general or the advertising
space you know as the ceo of humans
you're in charge of under of figuring
out where is the vision of not just
humans but of the marketing world how do
you see it
my take on that
it's a very good question and i see you
know the the advertising
paradigm changes entirely
meaning you see more and more brands
that are relay on creators that are more
creators oriented you can see creators
that are doing marketing strategies
they're doing marketing distribution
they create the content they sell the
content
so
i see the future goes directly to the
creators when it comes to
managing the entire marketing uh
you know division of brands and also
having their own white label brands
branded with their names on it
as
merchants
and you can see the you can still
many brands like pretty little thing in
america you can see adika the israeli
example
which are relay rely on the creators are
creators oriented you can see creators
choosing the clothings within the
shopping malls in a fashion shops
they'll go and they choose the content
that you're going to sell
right in the shop
so i do believe that they're going to
change the landscape and i
based on the numbers what you can see
and that's these are facts is that the
brands
keep in increasing the influencer
budgets if it was five percent
three years ago from your marketing from
your online marketing budget you can see
now that the average is around 20
from your online advertising budget wow
so
yes and as much more you have
micro and nano creators that joins the
community and make more
powerful content you'll see more budgets
and that's where it's going
are you more of a
marketer technologist
entrepreneur leader
where what what who is who is liam today
that's a good one uh i've started as the
technical
technical guy i
together with the rest of the founders i
developed the platform
but after a year i stopped developing i
started to do some calls i met the
clients i understood the clients
i can say now that i'm more of a people
person rather than computers person and
i'll put myself in the
you know
technologic
marketer if you want but
somewhere in between
going back to
this journey of yours transitioning as
an officer
you know in the idf working on some
critical missions and and today you're
you know you're you have this unique
perspective you're going from you know
something that is deep rooted you know
national security and you're
transitioning more to to brand and
marketing things that a lot of a lot of
times technologists may look at and and
you know scoff or think that it's not
you know it's not the most important
thing i personally disagree but how how
do you balance it for yourself what is
how do you sort of look back on this
journey of yours and make sense of it
well i think
you know it's a deep question i think
it's all about satisfaction and how do
you feel when you get up in the morning
i love to
i mean i smile for the following
almost five years when i get up in the
morning since i released from the army
and reason i'm smiling is that i'm doing
something that i enjoy doing and i build
something and i feel like
you know together with my co-founders
obviously and the rest of the humans
company we're building something great
we see the clients you know we have more
than 300 advertisers
and we're we're doing three times on
revenues since night
2019 each year we're doing three times
each year on the revenues and it's it
makes me feel like you know
it's you can't you can't put a price on
that feeling so i guess that's what
makes sense to me
i love it if you're looking now at other
people other young entrepreneurs whether
they may be
leaving the army or maybe they're
leaving a good college where they were
studying a specific field
and you know they're looking for this
thing this passion they're looking for
what they want to do what what can you
now a few years down the line share with
them you know how to even gain the
confidence to go and pursue something
that others around them may think is
completely
ridiculous that's another very good
question um boy you have very good
questions
i would i would say
um you have to focus on the signs that
you get from your environment and
to get signs you have to share you have
to dare and if you share your thoughts
and you share your ideas and your dog
you're not afraid of i know a lot of
entrepreneurs that says i have an idea
but i won't tell you because you might
take it you know right
it's not the approach every aha moment
that i have i'm sharing with my with my
friends and that's how i got my
co-founders to work together with me
and that's how i got the science from
the environment
so
i think the first and foremost advice
because you have a lot of advices but
number one
share and dare that's the best advice i
can get
share and dare i love it leave i think
that the journey that you're on is so
awesome
uh influencer marketing has been
something that
uh has been something you know that i've
been thinking about deeply because i've
been looking at the way that we as you
know we as
consumers around the world are are
thinking through
and how we make decisions and we're all
constantly talking about this this idea
of impulsive bank and it's been such a
problem for me this idea that brands may
be leveraging our cognitive biases to
make us buy something and all of a
sudden an influencer marketing it feels
much more organic there's somebody that
i trust especially the micro influencers
that often than not i guess
or also will also believe in what
they're doing and these are no smaller
perhaps smaller campaigns than the
trillion dollar campaigns of the regular
eye you know glasses that you see on the
ielon highways and these are people that
actually share you know organically with
a little script what they think and and
i think that it makes advertising in the
marketing world just a little bit better
than what it is and so and obviously you
know your personal journey and the
journey of humans and the growth is
phenomenal and and anyone going into
your website immediately you can see the
incredible things that you're doing and
the traffic that you have there and so
it was a lot of fun for me i'm going to
check out this hbo series and thank you
very much it was awesome
[Music]